the next item on our agenda being his
statement as vice president of the
commission High representative for
foreign affairs
his statement on the death of Masha
amini and the repression of women's
rights protesters in Iran
Mr Burrell
as soon as you've taken your seat sir
I will ask you
to
please without further Ado move to the
speaker's pulpit
but of course I will give you a few
seconds Sir
just to catch your breath
Mr Burrell
now it's your turn
and if you are ready the floor is yours
no if you have excuse me president
excuse me honorable members I was
running from one phone call to a meeting
but here am I sorry for being for being
late
Mr President Mr President honorable
members of the European Parliament
it's important to have this opportunity
to discuss today what is happening
across Iran
after the death of a young woman
was arrested by the police
and was
appeared dead was killed
during his arrest
in the police station
let me express my condolences to the
family
this is something that has to be said
although
it's not going to be very useful for
them
also let me Express
our
admiration for the demonstration mainly
women
and Men also across Iran protest him by
their by her killing
and the repression that they have
suffered
that has a
that has Costa
tens of people killed
these are facts it's not they are not
opinions these are facts
on the streets of Iran
the repression of the demonstrators has
left behind tens of people killed
mashamini was only 22 years old
she was visiting the capital of her
country
and the morality police even the name
morality police sounds
bizarre to our hearers
they train a mistreated hair simply
because of hair head scarf
and she ended up in hospital where she
died shortly after these are facts
following that following her passing
should I say her killing
we have seen a wave of indignation of
outrage
turning into National white protest in
Iran
Iranians
and especially young Iranians
have taken the streets to express their
anger
desperations for a better future free
from oppression
there are countless testimonies of brain
women and men expressing their descent
and their cities
on a social media
we have seen them chanting woman life
freedom
three key words
busy Daniel women have been the force
driving The Descent
they ask for respect Justice and
equality
nothing more
nothing less
as the European Union Representatives we
call immediately for the Iranian
authorities to ensure
the respect of fundamental rights of
Iranian citizens
in a meeting in New York
president Michelle and I had with
Iranian president Rezi
we raised this situation directly to him
and call for accountability for the
death of Masha many and restrained in
the government's reaction to the
demonstrations
unfortunately did not happen
numerous reports clearly show
that the response of the Iranian
security and police forces has been
disproportionated and resulted as he
said in tens of dozens or lives lost
many more have been injured and detained
including several journalists covering
the events
and we have
to see clear indications
of a credible investigation that could
ensure accountability for what has
happened
accountability not at all
also the internet has been shut down in
many areas of the country
Iranians and the world lost access to
information of what what was happening
there as well as the opportunity to use
online platforms to express their
descent which is another deliberated
violation of freedom of expression in
the country
I think it's important here at the
European Parliament to show a strong and
United reaction
by the European Union
on my side on behalf of the 27 member
states a publicly expressed in my
Declaration of September 25th
the widespread and disproportionated use
of force against non-violent protesters
and consider that the way it is
unjustifiable and unacceptable
people in Iran as anywhere else
have the right to peaceful protest
it's as simple as that
and it's clear that this right has not
been insured
together with the member stage we will
continue to consider all the options of
our disposal
including restrictive measures
to address the killing of Masha mini and
the way Iranian Security forces have
been responded to the demonstration
I will raise these at the next farenga
First Council with my colleagues
and what I am saying restrictive
measures
I am using the wording of the treaty
because in the treaty
you will not found the word sanctions
the only thing that you will find that
treaty is restrictive measures
and that's that that's it what I'm
talking about thank you
thank you
very much vice president
and I now call the chair of the Foreign
Affairs committee David McAllister
thank you Mr President Mr High
representative vice president ladies and
gentlemen dear colleagues
the massive protests that erupted
following the death of Maja amini in
police custody of spread over to 171
cities in all 31 provinces of Iran
the people are protesting against a
deeply corrupt and violent regime that
systematically oppresses women and
responds to political resistance with
brutal violence and repression
the violent Crackdown of the Muller
Security Forces on Peaceful protesters
must stop immediately
the council
ought to impose tough sanctions
responding to Serious human rights
violations as soon as possible
call them restrictive measures call them
tough sanctions the main thing is they
will be adopted sooner the better
the regime in Tehran has maneuvered
itself into a dead end
as our president Roberta metzola stated
yesterday here in the plenary we as
European Parliament stand in solidarity
with the brave women and men
and all their Democratic aspirations in
their fight
for women's human and minority rights
for the free flow of information and
access to Internet and for a free
secular and Democratic Republic thank
you
[Applause]
yes thank you very much I'd now like to
hand the floor to the chair the
president of the group the progressive
Alliance of socialism Democrats Mrs
Garcia Perez gracias thank you president
High representative
in the middle of uh 21st century there
is a police force in Iran which is there
to check the respect of clothing
standards by women this police force
detained a young woman because according
to them she was showing more hair than
she should from under her head scarf
this young woman did not leave the
police station alive that they took her
to incredible but it's true it's a
nightmare and this is the reality that
all women experience in Iran because
they're seen as
citizens of a second category as
property of their husband their father
their brother if a man kills his
daughter he'll be sent to prison for
just a few years because there are no
laws that protect women but if a woman
kills a man who has raped her she is
hanged the following day it Iranian
regime
is repressing the protesters violently
and brutally under women obviously here
are the first to protest because right
from the outset the authorities try to
reduce them to nothing but women have
been fighting right from the beginning
they've managed to achieve small
victories but unfortunately it's not
enough the death of Mata amini has
lit a flame which could perhaps lead to
the end of a dark regime which is
anchored in the Middle Ages and we've
seen that more and more Iranians are
raising their voices and going out into
the streets to protest risking their
lives and there are many people who have
died as a result of these protests this
has not been admitted by the Iranian
authorities the renegotiation of the
nuclear agreement with Iran which is
ongoing at the moment and the specific
position of the country in the middle of
an energy crisis around the world
means that we cannot look away we have
to look clearly what's happening in Iran
and Europe has to respond Europe has to
support the women in Iran because it's
the women in Iran who are leading this
protest
women
lives and freedom so Iranian women We
Stand By You
is
accidentally
thank you president
[Music]
was detained beaten on the way to police
station and and beaten to death there
unfortunately her murder
is nothing unusual
casual it's part of a state policy
against women's rights
and so amini today
has inspired thousands of of women to be
brave enough to go out on the street and
protest against a regime which for 43
years has sought to reduce them to
exploitation
oppression and exclusion
Iranian Society has come out onto the
streets in support of the women High
representative
they're still there calling for their
freedom
against a repressive dictatorial
Theocratic regime
that's why they're calling for Real
Change
they're calling for a democratic regime
violence to repress the protest is
nothing new nor is impunity in Iran we
saw what happened in the Protestant 2019
and 2021 and April of this year there
the European Union
in 2019 issued penalties against of
central army it was then in charge of
the Revolutionary guards
now he's a member of the National
Security Council
in charge of organizing the repression
of the the protests with live fire and
so high representative we need to renew
and update the sanctions we need to
extend the sanctions
that's how we can stand by the people of
Iran
um on behalf of all the women who who
have um died because of them
events unfolding in Iran
are unprecedented particularly over the
last week I would like to give my
unwavering support to all the protesters
who have taken to the streets to protest
we're talking about many casualties and
we're talking about many still
protesting against the murder of Masa
amini who was
rested tortured and killed
the Iranian authorities two weeks later
have still not taken any responsibility
for what happened
we should call upon the authorities in
Iran to
conduct an investigation into what
happened to make sure that human rights
Defenders are protected this is yet
another case of discrimination against
women because of discriminatory codes
pertaining to clothing
women in Iran have been protesting
peacefully against
rules pertaining to the hijab and
they're protesting because of the breach
their fundamental rights we stand in
solidarity with all of them
these protests have become a movement
and it's a sign of disquiet that is
being expressed by women and men in Iran
against a government that is
systematically oppressing all dissidents
as far as the European Union is
concerned and its member states we would
urge you to take all available channels
in order to
put pressure upon the authorities of
Iran to put an end to these laws and
these practices that deprive women of
their rights and their autonomy
respect for human rights has to be part
and parcel of the relations that we have
within with the European Union and Iran
we cannot have a situation where these
rights are not respected this you know
is a situation where we cannot leave
these women alone thank you
thank you very much
Mr jeopard girl is the next speaker
thank you president
amini a young woman 22 years old
was has died beaten by the morality
police because she was not wearing her
Islamic Veil correctly
and then another person was killed by
police bullets for the same reason and
very many young women in irania Iran are
fighting for their rights but for many
years now the European Union
has been taking part in the promotion to
where wearing this veil in the European
Union
and the European commission co-financed
this campaign saying that Liberty is in
the hijab last February during the
course of the conference on the future
of Europe
this slide was uh published a future is
in your hands and it shows a woman
wearing a hijab this is a future of
Europe that our people do not want on
the 21st of September during the course
of a campaign for Erasmus Plus the
commission showed this slide showing a
girl wearing a veil a young girl wearing
a veil and on again on the 21st of
September femiso a women's movement
um
in the on the premises of European
Parliament and on an invitation of a
socialist group
they did it was a basically a
proselytism exercise that for avails for
women and 23 million euro have been
put forward two different associations
uh refusing to integrate with European
values and some of these people have
come along here to speak against the
islamophobian friends this is not
acceptable
the citizens expect of the European
Union that they do not convert to
islamism and we do not want their
support for the ayatollahs thank you
Mr gaho I would have to say that
what
you've just said and the views you've
expressed in your statements are not
in line with the rules of procedure and
I would urge you to respect the rules of
procedure of the house it's so
I'd now like to turn to asita canco you
have the floor dear colleagues the women
who are now rising up against the
Islamic brutality in Iran know what
freedom is and why we must protect it
those who defend the Earth's heart in
Europe should take a good look at these
women and learn what real courage is
it's not in the Veil
it's also not inside a dependent man
a dependent man is a healthy Man Who
Cannot cook his own meal who cannot do
his own dishes who cannot clean his own
house control his own sexuality or his
own or do his own damn laundry or be
responsible of his own life I can
understand that men cannot bear children
but I strongly refuse to be enslaved as
a woman refuse to see women be enslaved
today tortured and killed because they
want to wear a t-shirt this darkness
that many still carry must stop
therefore all men should become
independent and self-sufficient that is
your best contribution to the
emancipation of women an independent man
is healthy is a healthy man sorry he's a
healthy man who does all his things by
himself and picks the right side in the
fight for Freedom it's a man who is not
scared of women's intelligence and
potential not scarce of their opinions
not scared of their ideas or sexuality
it's a man who knows that men are
responsible of their own sexuality it's
a man who does not expect his wife or
daughter to wear the hijab to protect
men from their femininity he clearly
takes their sight in the fight against
the subjection of women as women we must
also take our own sight and fight to be
first work to be together to be
respected the Iranian women are showing
us the way a woman died for Freedom
together we need to say that we
understand how they feel and support
them
yeah thank you very much
[Music]
shame
shame on those who murdered Marsa amini
and so many other women just because of
lock of hair was sticking out of their
Veil shame on the militias of the
Iranian Islamic dictatorship who take
away women's freedom of movement shame
on this obscurantist patriarchal regime
that gags crushes and imprisons women
and all those who mobilize alongside
them shame on the theocracy of the
mullers whose oppression of women and
the obligation to wear the veil are the
Keystone shame on Emmanuel macron who
shook hands with president ricey when
the police were firing on the crowd
under his orders shame on the heads of
state who just stare at their shoes when
the Iranians who are mobilizing need
support and their executioners need
punishment
with these simple words Iranian women
are leading the Battle of all women
Under Fire and bringing with them a
whole people United against corruption
dictatorship and Injustice their courage
is humbling our solidarity must never
waver we must fight everywhere and all
the time against the oppression of women
for the conquest of their freedom in
Iran as well as for the defense of their
fundamental rights to control their own
bodies in the United States in Hungary
in Poland what hypocrisy on the part of
the extreme right to come and lecture us
here because you are the first to
actually prevent women from
having right over their bodies so as a
tribute to the struggle of Iranian women
I would like to end with the lines of a
poet Mona busway who was arrested for
these words her hair a flag that the
Knight has soiled will take it back in
the shadow of your claws o magma of Lies
oh you frightened one will take this
country back from your clutches thank
you may I see
[Applause]
spectacles thank you
duckies
yes thank you very much we condemn the
assassination of Masa amini
as an Iranian
the assassination of uh Mata amini and
the deaths of many people during the
protests the and the arrests as well
are proof of the violence of the the
violent nature of this state and the
oppression that exists in this country
but then we have the hypocrisy of the
European Union and we would also have to
condemn that
we seem to have a la carte sensitivity
when it comes to women in Iran because
there are women in other countries that
are suffering in a similar fashion but
we don't condemn that
the protests in Iran are being
manipulated and being turned into an
instrument of the imperialist fight
which is being waged in a similar way in
Ukraine
these protests are being used
in favor of the of capitalist
exploitation
and submission of women of this is
Fitzgerald is the next one
uh thank you vice president I
representative women in Iran are
fighting for their fundamental rights
their freedom the shocking and unlawful
death of a young woman of 22 Maza Amina
is a stark reminder of the abuse and
violence women face every day from the
regressive Iranian regime
women and men have rightly taken to the
streets to protest at the barbaric and
honestly sickening treatment of women by
the Iranian State and their so-called
morality police
what
morality I ask
whose values whose morals certainly not
women's we in this chamber must join the
Iranian people and condemn this use of
violence against women
and the continued use of such
disproportionate violence against
protesters is abhorrent and emblematic
of such an autocratic regime
we must support women to have choice in
the way that they live we must support
the fundamental rights of all women to
live life as they see fit
free from state-sponsored violence the
stories emerging are really totally
unacceptable they are Dreadful and I
urge the high representative to do
everything in his power to take action
against the state in a United Way across
Europe like so many of the women of Iran
Maza was Brave and courageous we must
ensure that her death was not in vain
thank you
thank you
Miss Evan incia about the next one
her name was Gina Masa amini a young
Kurdish girl in Iran with her whole life
ahead of her deprived of her life by men
and a regime who thinks they have the
right to control women for over 40 years
women girls minorities and oppositional
groups have lived in horror the Iranian
feminist Revolution is a democratic
Revolution that is taking place right
now the autocratic regime I think that
they can suffocate and silence the
people but what they do is to fuel the
anger
right now Iranian Kurdish baluch and
many other groups especially the women
and young leveraging their righteous
wrath and Shout the day of the regimes
are numbered
the cruel morality police and all of
those in the government behind the
oppression of the people must be
sanctioned the Discrimination laws that
constitutes the basis of the gender
apartheid in the country must be
abolished the murderers of Jean and all
those freely demonstrating and
protecting protesting must be brought to
Justice we need to end impunity to be
silent easy to be compliant compliance
can't be the way forward for the
International Community if we truly
stand for what we preach democracy human
rights equality and justice the cause of
all women and people in Iran is our
cause their freedom is our freedom
Azadi woman life freedom
[Applause]
you are the next one
dear colleagues colleagues they're high
representative
please allow me to start my remarks with
a message addressed not to this chamber
but to the women of Iran
your courage is breathtaking
as you rise up against Injustice as you
dare to defy the oppressive regime you
inspire the fight for women's rights
everywhere and as you honor the memory
of masamini who was brutally murdered
you are teaching the word a lesson in
solidarity
so that no women is harassed or killed
because of a bigoted dress code ever
again
We Salute and admire your bravery and
colleagues our support cannot be limited
only to words European diplomacy needs
to swing into action now we need
targeted personal sanctions travel bans
asset phrases against members of the
Iranian regime and also including
careful and strict implementation of
every single existing sanction and we
also need to help those whose lives are
in danger by issuing humanitarian visas
the people of Iran who take the streets
the women who remove or burn their head
scarves they are risking their lives
doing so they deserve help from the
European Union and the International
Community as a whole let's show them
that we are on their side thank you very
much
thank you
the next speaker is Mrs Dino Riva
gracias
thank you woman life and freedom this is
just more than a fighting slogan
It's been a
shouted out by a Kurdish Woman by
Kurdish women Iranian women it means
that a society cannot exist without
women who are free if we take a look at
a world where we see ever more
totalitarianism then the word of Freedom
level Freedom has uh is associated with
women Hanan Kia uh amasa amini and
others and women in Iran are risking
their lives for the right to life on
their own terms and to destroy the
patriarchy and the regime which is
suppressing them discriminating against
them and submitting them and their fight
for and their resistance as an example
for all of us from here I would like to
send out a message of admiration I just
like to say that we stand with you and
we will always stand with women who are
demanding freedom for themselves and
their societies
[Music]
thank you
Madam Anna from Frisco
grazia president thank you president
and thank you as well hi representative
many of us would have
liked to see the European Union being
equally bold
in boycotting
the
inauguration person uh
we thought the elections were fraudulent
well shouldn't you be clearer about the
sanctions
make them the toughest and truest
sanctions we have
and we have to recognize all the
massacres carried out by the Iranian
regime since 1988 right up until today
we need to be clearer in defining as a
crime against humanity any arbitrary
imprisonment torture
and and killing to which women and girls
and all the minorities in Iran are
subjected
need to bring about International
investigations into the
Injustice is perpetrated by Rosie and
his whole regime against the Iranian
people
they're making a contribution to
humanity only death and Terror
we have to be clearly opposed to this
fail which brings blood and death
and the women the hair of the women of
Iran is are which hold out a future of
Freedom Mr Charlie why must
thank you
thank you Mr President
evil empire that's what President Reagan
dared to call the Soviet Union remember
that
Soviet dissident Nathan choresky does
he fondly remarked
I remember what a burst of enthusiasm
this gave us when the West finally saw
the Soviet Union for what it was there
would be hope for victory
words matter
the Iranian people beg us to be their
voice and we should
words must be matched by action and this
requires soul-searching here in Europe
political prisoners and young girls
don't get a burst of enthusiasm when
European politicians done hijabs in
front of the regime in Tehran
Iranians supplied suicide drones to
Russia are used to kill ukrainians
while Brussels clings on to a dead
nuclear deal
where are the magnitsky sanctions
against the ruling Elite already
will protesters chanting zen Zendaya
also the woman life Freedom be given a
hope for victory as liberals and
socialists normalize relations with the
murdering mullahs Mr High representative
join me in declaring what the brave
Iranian people already know all too well
the Islamic Republic is an evil Republic
[Music]
okay
and bought this chocolate thank you
Mrs Cornelia earns
well yes
what does it say about a regime when
this regime
calls uh causes the death of a young
woman because she wasn't wearing her
veil properly what it says is that
we have to close the chapter on a regime
of this kind anybody who in the name of
God kills people
um is not uh respecting God and we will
never stop defending women who try and
fight against this kind of suppression
and we will never stop
and protesting about Iran with our
hearts and souls because anybody
protesting in Iran are Justified
women Iranian women have long been a
catchword for
uh protest and freedom because they want
to be free to be able to breathe and
live their lives as they want and to be
accepted as a women
when it comes to the desire for freedom
and the equality you cannot just
suffocated
oh damn it Iran Iran is a beautiful
country it has
long-reaching history and culture but I
think the time has come to start a new
chapter
written in a woman's hand because enough
is enough sleeping time thank you very
much
Mr Buddhism
he's a cry for freedom
for they freedom and for the freedom of
the Forgotten women of Afghanistan or
Africa we respect their protest for what
is this they rebel against the
dictatorship of men who imprisoned them
bully them Charter them limit their
lives simply because they are women and
want to live in equality
there is a common threat that connects
this protest with the protest of
previous generations of women who talk
to the streets because they were not
allowed to vote they were not allowed to
be involved in politics they were not
allowed to work within the same jobs as
men they were not allowed to earn the
same salary as them
they ask for complete Freedom they ask
to be able to live and to do with their
future and their buddies what they want
decide their lives for themselves in
full freedom
that's why they should answer the other
freedom freedom freedom and we must
listen to this cry we must help it thank
you very much
thank you
alejos
that was yours
17 days have passed since protests began
following the killing of mashamini in
Iranian police facilities
how many Iranians have been killed
hundreds
how many have been arrested or injured
thousands we don't know for sure
women are beaten and dragged Away by
police but let us get it right
this is not only about monetary bailing
or jihab this is about basic Freedom
this is about a regime founded on
systematic repression and cruelty
against his people a regime headed by
someone fully involved in the massacre
of 1988 a crime against humanity that
has already come to European courts as a
Swedish court has imposed a life
sentence and an Iranian official for
taking part in this crime there is an
uprising going on in Iran and we have
not only took on then repression but to
support the victims of repression we
need to send a clear sign of our concern
and condemnation but also an an
equivocal message of support Europe
means pluralism democracy freedom of
religion respect for all beliefs equal
rights between men and women and those
Iranians are struggling for the rights
risking their lives
deserve to see Europe firmly on their
side Europe at its best
friendly supportive and committed
there should be specific demands to the
Iranian government on the release of
prisoners and accountability of
repetitors no matter how long it takes
but neither the nuclear deal or the old
resources of program can justify turning
a blind eye or water down our response
appeasement we should know never works
[Music]
Mrs
[Music]
um
thank you since the death
of massage meaning it's the young woman
the victim of the Iranian morality
police
victim of not having won her hit her
properly
and the people have died from thousand
been arrested for calling for their
freedom
the the clerics say that um these
demonstrations are being stirred up by
Foreign interference but this protesters
are calling for just one thing the end
of a regime which suppresses them
closes them up and and masochists them
the EU is proposing
to
show its to deal with the regime we have
to show our solidarity
with the demonstrators
and human rights Defenders
in the country
we have to call for targeted sanctions
and include human rights in all
discussions and agreements with Iran
thank you
thank you Mrs Hill developments
thank you very much and good evening
dear president dear High representative
dear colleagues
over 100 deaths and still counting
we all know the brutal story
public protest in Iran broke out after a
mini diet in Cassidy after she was
arrested
for not wearing the hijab correctly
we cannot close our eyes to these
atrocities we must pursue a clear
strategy in which we put women's rights
on the top of the agenda
as Madeleine Albright once said
there is a special place in hell for
women who don't help women
therefore Mr well if you don't want to
go to hell and I think you don't want to
go to hell I really urge you provide
access to a European universities
support Civil Society in their fight for
women's rights protect human rights
Defenders and Target directly the
leaders and people who are responsible
for these crimes let's never give up on
woman the life and the Liberty in Iran
they need our help thank you very much
thank you thank you very much Mrs Alice
thank you very much president
it started with yina Masa amini
but there were people imprisoned there
were people injured there were people
murdered there were many many more faces
and just as many names
the executioners the murderers those
complicit there are also many of them we
know who they are and we know that they
should be held accountable for their
actions what about us the rest of us
those of us who can make a choice choose
our lives as we should and do what we
can with what we have Peace and Freedom
is not something that comes free of
charge handed to you on a silver platter
there are brave women and children in
Iran who are taking to the streets and
they have proven how expensive freedom
is what a price you have to be
I think that at the end of the day
we will have to see whether this battle
was worth it was it
worth it or not only subsequently well
we know it seems to me that the peace
movement Freedom Movement in Iran needs
to have every support from us
then zendigi Azadi very much
our next speaker is Mr the ubo
thank you
[Applause]
whatever
honorable president
when the religious police batters a
woman to death in Iran
the feminists in Europe remains silent
other religious rules more important
than This Woman's right to live who
would have defended her here in Europe
would she
even have been accused of being
islamophobic I would not be surprised by
that either
Europe can and must condemn the
repression of women by Iran and Islam
but will it change anything
even if the current extremist Islamic
theocracy were overthrown it would just
be replaced by a new Islamic regime
would it be even more cruel or more
moderate is the only question Islam and
its idea of women will not disappear
anywhere
importing Western democracy to the
Muslim countries hasn't worked out to
date
neither did the earlier Arab revolutions
changed the situation in any way in its
neighboring country Afghanistan they
have set up a new regime of Terror and
what about the future of Europe
dozens of millions of people that have
been fostered
on that religion have been received here
by Open Arms in Europe and we have seen
the results terror strikes all over
would you finally learn its lesson thank
you
Mrs Anna fortiga
thank you president
Mr High rep vice president
Masa amini the young Iranian woman of
Kurdish origin
has been was beaten to death but so by
so-called law enforcement forces of of
Iran
the regime directly responsible for her
killing as well as for
violent Crackdown murderous violent
Crackdown of of massive protests that
followed this this crime
is has been LED for for already a few
years by President raisy person directly
responsible for judicial killings
crime against humanity
it towards the end of of 1980s
top impunity for this kind of crimes
High rep there is highest time for us to
impose
uh as you as you say restrictive
measures against those who lead this
kind of Barbarians regimes thank you
president president honorable colleagues
the murder of Martha amini a young
Iranian Woman by the so-called morality
police is deeply disturbing ours is the
brutal violence with which protests have
been repressed we're talking about
hundreds of
fatalities casualties people being put
Behind Bars by this murderous regime in
Iran for too long for too long on the
right and on the left it has been
supported by political forces even in
this house I'm impressed by the courage
of young people in Iran young women in
particular they're risking their lives
for a life in Freedom self-determination
and who are not being intimidated by the
regime of the mullahs the Revolutionary
guards and their Terror
this is a call for freedom and we must
heed this call for Freedom we cannot
just speak about solidarity the European
Union needs to really Target the regime
in Iran with sanctions that is what we
owe to the courageous people of Iran
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker
so hi commissioner I deeply regret the
death of Masha meaning she was arrested
for improperly wearing the hijab a
symbol of faith and I had to experience
and explain inexplicable amount of
Violence by the Iranian morality police
which led to her debt
and it's as if the faith can come from
the force God is not in beating but in
loving
I strongly condemned the excessive
actions by the Iranian authorities
against the Nationwide protests that
they have erupted after the incidents
the Iranian people are gathering in the
streets to call for freedom freedom of
religion freedom to exercise their basic
human rights
Iran is a part to several international
human rights treaties but they fail to
implement abiding principles and tried
in these legal documents and I call on
our European diplomatic services and the
International Community to monitor this
process and to push for objective
investigation of all other arrests and
incidents relating to the protests thank
you thank you again
so
thank you very much next is Mr Robert
biedron
[Music]
copy it is
thank you very much president
the situation is extremely regrettable
for women there is no protection for
them against uh forced marriages being
raped within their marriage this is
something which is a daily situation in
Iran for 17 days very brave women and
girls have raised their voices
they are protesting against the regime
they want to have their own rights they
want to fully exercise these rights and
so the question is what will we do
as a democracy to help them
Mr President it's not just a moral
obligation it's also a democratic
obligation
we have to put in place sanctions
against the Iranian regime we have to
raise this in every single conversation
with the regime we have to raise the
issue of Human Rights we cannot leave
these women alone these women must know
that they will never be alone again
that's our responsibility
thank you very much Mr benef
500 800 3 000 dead perhaps more we know
that you the bazan you're not going to
be able to eliminate them to keep your
power yes
this is a popular Uprising it is a
women's Uprising that is Uprising that
is standing up for women and for freedom
and yes perhaps you could snuff it out
with your arms and your cynicism but be
careful you will remember I'm sure you
will remember the masses resembled in
the presidential election in 1997 when
your people were able to vote for a
candidate for changemen and you'll
remember the uprising against the Sham
re-election of Mahmoud Ahmad in 2009 and
you will remember of course the
demonstrations in 2019 2020 and you'll
remember the 8 million signatures
against the execution of political
prisoners
you will remember and you will never
forget that the Iranian uh anger is only
growing against your bloodthirsty
incompetence and you must remember of
course that your end is nigh the next
one is Mr shanik Shadow
my colleagues
how can we characterize this
extraordinary movement being boldly
spearheaded by women since the
assassination of masalamini and so many
others it's not a Revolt it's a
revolution not an islamist Revolution a
revolution of the mullers which brought
in a regime of Oppression and
assassinations and the imprisonment of
demonstrators Human Rights Defenders and
journalists this regime which
inspires fear in women and represses
them using the law rather what we are
seeing is a revolution of consciences
and hearts who have had enough of being
suffocated and of suffering this is a
revolution of a civilization women are
tearing off their veils and they are
proclaiming Liberty equality and The
Sisterhood and that is why you must
sanction the authors of these crimes we
must stand against those who sow Terror
and stand alongside those who fight for
women because their values are those of
Europe
merci Madame Isabella
foreign
and how many others there are many of
course that have not even been reported
on in the newspapers and I'm sure that
we need to see just how many women will
have to die before Europe takes a
position against in the islamization of
Europe and this regime in place it is
time for Brussels to move away from
ambiguity if we want to stand with these
women who are currently combating who
are dying to fight against this regime
and not just use propaganda for the use
of headscarves or social methods that
would run counter to these women who are
so courageous women who are standing up
and saying women life liberty Brussels
you cannot run counter the to the trust
of these women who believe that they
will be able to live free of this uh
some
um oppression we must stand up for our
European values at this time because
what is currently happening in a country
that seems very far away is without a
doubt something that could just be a
Harbinger for the future here thank you
I'd like to express my condolences to
the family of shamini as well as other
families whose members were killed
during the protests
um it is a clear sign that change must
come the current political direction is
untenable I would like to pay tribute to
Iranian women who have gone up to the
streets they deserve our support our
respect we need to do our utmost to
support the opposition and the
protesters who fight against the brutal
regime's repressions they fight for
fundamental rights and freedoms without
uh help Iran will continue to export
terrorism we wish to gain nuclear
weapons and provide threat to other
countries we need to send a clear
message that these repressions will not
Escape Justice thank you speaker is
thank you president
do you know who Zina amini is yes
she is the woman who paid with her life
for being free
however everybody here has called her
Masha ignoring her coolish identity
women in Iran are showing us how to
fight for Freedom sadly this struggle
has also become the perfect platform to
show modern superiority without any
re-election this is why nobody mentions
that a mini was a Kurdish or that the
most brutal repression in this crisis is
happening in Kurdistan These Wings
remain hidden because they exposed
uncomfortable contradictions like
defending Kurdistan is difficult if one
wants to be friends with turkey or
that being that being what is being done
to protect women in our countries that
are forced by their communities to where
religious garments is basically nothing
we call this religious religious freedom
knowing that religion or Freedom has
nothing to do with it the struggle of
women in Iran is the New Frontier of
human rights of Hume of Human Rights
about hypocrisy to support them with
facts thank you thank you very much
thank you thank you very much
Mr President High representative
colleagues
there are moments in the history of
man's struggle for Liberty
when only poetry will do
I recommend to you a song called
Sherwin hajpur whose lyrics are put
together from messages sent by
protesters
that describe what this is about
for dancing in the streets
for fear when kissing
for yearning of just normal life
for this polluted air for Tears with no
end
for this forced heaven
for pills of nerves and insomnia
for women life freedom for freedom for
freedom
dear Iranian sisters I hope you win this
but you are already Our Heroes from the
bottom of my heart I salute you
[Applause]
thank you very much colleagues
after the death of my grandfather
shortly after the founding of the
Islamic Republic my family fled to
Europe to live in Freedom
I have him to thank that here as a young
woman I can stand here in public and to
speak out the same Freedom that these
women are on the streets in Iran
campaigning for for years they have been
oppressed and he moved to Freedom
punished
they are oppressed through their
religion their identity they're told
what to wear
we
what we cannot see is that these people
are there they're fighting alone against
a regime without Scruples our support
from Europe must be more tangible we
need to broaden sanctions from our side
we must uh punish them in terms of visas
we must ensure that Asylum is provided
we must speak out loudly to strengthen
the voice of the protesters in Iran for
Xena Masha Amani for women for life for
freedom
I had sleeping tank
thank you thank you very much
women life liberty
these words have been written out across
Iran for 18 days now since Xena Masha
amini was killed
in the north of Iran she was young she
was Kurdish and according to Authority
she was not wearing her hijab correctly
she won't be the last either because
we've had many many deaths and thousands
of arrests over the last 18 days these
women are courageous they're being
joined by men and students and sports
stars we've got Federer Azul from the
national football team an icon who is
defying the authorities on behalf of
women and what are we doing Mr Burrell
we've got seven countries calling for
additional sanctions targeted smart
sanctions and I was delighted to hear
you supporting those calls for sanctions
it is absolutely vital that we respond
because we
have our freedoms we should say her name
Masha amini
foreign
dear colleagues human dignity Freedom
democracy values that we claim to hold
very dear in the European Union values
that are the basis of the functioning of
our societies and now we see a protest
movement in Iran that is fighting for
exactly the these values led by Brave
women a protest movement that has come
together and that can change not only
Iran but the whole region and eventually
the whole world with the false and
determination that is unprecedented
people are going to the streets and they
go to the streets knowing full well that
they can sacrifice their own life doing
this and they rightfully ask us what are
your words your declarations your
Banner's worth if now in this moment you
are not standing with us so the youth
response has to be clear more sanctions
a more determined and louder
condemnation of this brutal regime and
amplifying the voices of the people who
are protesting and who sacrificed so
much in this revolution thank you
thank you
Jordan padella
thank you very much president
thank you President
we need to give a moral and unanimous
support to Amin and to those that are
standing up they have decided to to
create this Uprising against the
imposition of the mullah and going all
the way to the death to fight for the
fact that they are absolutely on the
same footing as men but today I'd like
to really point out that the commission
is a very much contradictory they're
steeding out speaking out against the
Iran and yet at the time they've also
had a
a point at which they were not paying
attention to a situation of great
gravity so this is just a one story but
it's one that is of great importance
because it shows that there is an
islamism that is being supported by the
European taxpower fezimo for example
Muslim women that you roll out a red
carpet for at the European institutions
therefore you are not recognizing the
identity of our Nations and opening up a
migratory policy that is outrageous and
putting our continent in at the
um just in in a position of waiting for
islamization so a continent that is
absolutely
um one that should be of free men and
women Christianity and never of uh uh
fanaticism or headscarves or islamism
thank you
the first
thank you chair
dear commissioner
he kept on and I feel respect for the
flower in Iraq I have a huge amount of
respect for the men and women in Iran
who are standing up and opposing a
criminal regime this requires a lot of
courage
you don't really need much courage to
stand up here and say you're against
what's happening in Iran in Europe I can
dress however I want and I can speak out
however I wish those protesters in Iran
are endangering their lives in the hope
of a better future a safe free future
so that is the responsibility of each
government
these protesters need and deserve our
unconditional support not just because
of the unacceptable death of Masha amini
but as long as is necessary as long as
this unacceptable regime run by the
ayatollahs is still in power in Iran
Iranian women and all women around the
world
who are opposed to oppression let me
just say I see you and I hear you and I
admire all of you and I am by your side
thank you very much merci
Mission Revere
IGN
thank you very much
well what hypocrisy here in the chamber
this evening we have a contributing torn
apart by demonstrations in the wake of
the assassination masiyamini who was
arrested by the morality please for
infringement of the hijab laws and we
have the same people pursuing a policy
of the veil talking about the freedom of
the hijab saying how wonderful diversity
is well diversity is but the hijab will
never be a symbol of equality we've got
women in Iran risking their lives and we
have communication campaigns which are
being conducted by the islamists in Iran
now we have been presenting the hijab in
Europe
as a signal of Liberty chosen by women
now
you should be supporting Iranian women
who are taking the risk of walking the
streets with their heads uncovered so
you know enough is enough we have this
hypocrisy surrounding the Islamic Veil
which continues to be an instrument of
Oppression of men over women
our next speaker is Miss Anna Michelle
the death of Maha amini is shocking but
sadly it's not surprising it's not
surprising to the people of Iran whose
basic human rights are routinely
trampled on and it's not surprising to
the United States which is Accused by
Ayatollah Khomeini of instigating the
protests and it's not surprising to
Israel which Iran wants to wipe off the
face of the Earth it's not surprising to
the Islamic revolutionary guard Corps
which regularly engages in Terrorist
acts and is now carrying out raids on
the protesters
it's not surprising but it actually is
terrifying that all of this comes from a
country which is building nuclear
weapons it's even more sad that the
European Union's response is currently
basically statements and debates instead
of actions so please High representative
Please Mr Burrell
surprise us pleasantly and do something
I call upon you to immediately take
steps to designate the Islamic
revolutionary guard Corps as what it is
namely a terrorist organization thank
you
thank you
also our next dish uh
the Masa Mini
's death at the hands of the morality
police in Iran
because she didn't wear her hijab
correctly is in intolerable case of
violence and it violates the basic
rights of women
it almost seems impossible that
something like this could continue to
happen in our world that women are
subjected to this and yet it still
happens today it is a cry that we have
to put out to all Iranians
to support them they're being so
courageous and standing up for their
rights and the end of Oppression in
their country hi representative the
European Union absolutely needs to
continue to act within the context of
international organizations and with all
of its relations with other countries to
make sure that through all diplomatic
relations are fun founded in the respect
of women's rights and this Parliament
needs to do the same our foreign policy
absolutely needs to be an absolute
weapon to be able to stand up for these
rights and defend them through and
through colleague
is next
three weeks of continuous courage shown
by the women in Iran Persian azeri
Kurdish women are paying the Ultimate
Prize for Freedom their life
a courage that has not been met by you
Mr Burrell when you didn't take the
opportunity during the general assembly
in the U.N and took a stand for the
woman in Iran
enough for the press releases now enough
for the mumbling it's time to speak out
it's time to act the hands of the regime
of the mullahs in Iran is stained with
blood neither history nor Allah or God
Almighty will forgive you for the crimes
against humanity that you are committing
against your own citizens with the
peoples and the citizens of the EU
demand the unconditional and immediate
stop of all the violence against the
women and men in Iran until Iran is free
our Fury will be bigger than the
oppressors until the woman of Iran are
free we are going to stand with you
women life freedom
at sleeping time
[Applause]
colleague thank you very much this is a
difficult debate
and it's quite hard to break off
speakers when they come to their minute
or minute and a half speaking time it's
a very emotional difficult debate people
are saying things that need to be said
so I'm trying to be flexible when it
comes to the uh speaking time but I will
have to close the catch the eye speakers
list
and will only really be able to get two
or three people in
unfortunately under catch the eye
because of the way the speaking time is
going even though eight people have
asked for the floor so please uh I ask
for your understanding and please do try
and stick to the speaking time as far as
you can
so miss gregorova is the next speaker
woman life freedom I observe with deep
admiration the breathtaking courage with
which Iranian women stand these days
against the dictatorship of Khomeini and
his morality police the message of the
Iranian protests is universal and
resonates across the world it is heard
by women in Poland and the U.S who are
denied the right to their own bodies it
is heard by women in Italy where Ultra
conservative forces are coming to power
it is heard by women everywhere where
the same obscurants under different
symbols wait for the nearest opportunity
to trap free women in predetermined
roles that is why I think it is
essential that their slogans are heard
today in this room over and over again
thank you
thank you the next one is
thank you very much president colleagues
the death of Masha amini 22 years old
for an infringement of the hijab laws is
unacceptable
this is a symbol of Oppression
how are women in the world who still
live behind the fog of a veil
and we have
76 deaths and thousands of arrests in
the last two weeks alone and that is why
I call on our foreign ministry as well
as you Mr Burrell to use all the tools
within your power to make sure that
those in jail return home as soon as
possible amini and all the other matters
of the Iranian regime must not be
forgotten and that is why I want to
commend the efforts of the Italian
refugees Association which Advocates
that we light a candle so not
lose a sight of the memory of Iranian
women next one is Herman Dutch
president
thank you very much president there are
terrible things occurring in Iran we
have the police from the terrorist
regime of the
Ayatollah as a woman is beaten to death
and murdered by the police for having
shown her hair for having not worn her
Chad or her veil correctly
something that the EU uses for
propaganda and who that uh something
they use in their own advertising and
publicity we have the police who are
killing men and women who are protesting
against this monstrous regime more than
300 and this could just this may well be
the beginning of the end of this regime
we don't seem to be hearing too much in
the European media the Social Democratic
media we don't really hear it very much
because there are other interests at
Play
in
2019 there were 1 500 dead in the month
of December and just one month later we
were holding out our hand to this regime
of Assassins who had stained the streets
of Iran with blood
it seems that there are some very
powerful interests at play here the EU
needs to end its agreements with this
regime the EU needs to stop treating
Iran as if it were just another partner
they are a terrorist regime they cannot
be one of our par there cannot be one of
our partners in any case
we need to end this EU policy financed
by Communists in Spain
uh next week it is Mr David liger
on the way down
and the microphone's done
thank you
chair High representative
to the Iranian women the change makers
in Iran we support you I want to be
Crystal Clear we wholeheartedly support
the aspirations of the Iranian people
who want to live in a free stable
inclusive and Democratic country and we
strongly condemn the compulsory hijab
law we condemn the morality police and
we condemn the brutal repression and
violence but words are not enough
I call on the EU and the rest of the
world to take action we need an
investigation and we need accountability
the abusers must be punished actions do
speak louder than words that's why I
hope that the EU High representative
will never wear the hijab in meetings
with Iranian counterparts again the
former High representative Federica
Morini failed in representing our EU
values and that's why I hope the new
Swedish foreign minister will never wear
the hijab in meetings with Iranian
counterparts the former Swedish foreign
minister and Linda failed in
representing European values enough is
enough thank you
thank you
our next speaker is Mr bear Francesco
mayorino
is
we stand with the women in Iran that are
fighting on a daily basis in the name of
freedom and dignity
their combat is our combat
repression that has currently been
unfolding over the course of these weeks
it is impacting girls women and those
who are making decisions for themselves
we know that this has already been
something that has had an impact on our
people of culture of citizens that are
not in line of the authoritarian regime
in the course of these days we are
seeing violent persecutions torture
molestation
outrageous repression and we've seen
that um I mean his death death has led
to further deaths dozens at that our
institutions absolutely need to respond
using their diplomatic relations without
intimidation standing up helping the
young people of Iran those who keep
repeating the three words that I would
like to repeat here women freedom and
life
thank you very much
president
thank you very much Masha many 22 years
old right and Tehran at the hands of the
morality police because a little bit of
hair was showing from beneath her head
scarf and in Iran across the world as
well as in Afghanistan women have been
demonstrating this is a Revolt which has
been spearheaded by Iranian women along
with men in the face of a regime which
kills them and I commend the courage of
these women who are calling for their
rights to Freedom despite the
assassinations and oppression that
incurs the brutality of the regime has
been shown because of the scale of the
uprising and we should therefore condemn
this regime taking part in violence
against women and Iran in the United
Nations is investigating this violence
against demonstrators we owe Theirs to
Masha amini and all those those who hope
for a new world so let's stand up and
let us Echo the words of our Iranian
sisters women life freedom
Mercy thank you very much
hi representative the death of Masha
amini is a tragedy the Iranian people
have shown exceptional courage in the
face of repression I think the best way
to condemn the violence was to give the
floor to those who are actually
protesting I will quote a young Iranian
nameless but someone that can give us
hope this young Iranian was going to
leave their country but decided to stay
well might have a wrong and distorted
image from Iranian people especially
over the past decades but we want to
correct it we are not this government we
hate it we are Iranian from a country
with more than 2500 years history we
believe in love peace human rights we
hate brutal Islamic laws and for this
our children our young people are being
killed by the regime we might be
arrested or killed
and he continues that this is only the
beginning for a more profound change
they call on Europeans to help them to
avoid any kind of agreements or
compromises with the Iranian regime let
us support these young people in their
fight nice
thank you very much and before I hand
over
the presidential chair I'll give the
floor to Evelyn Regner be horrified how
the Iranian regime hunts down these
Brave Iranian women and men but at the
same time I'm proud very proud I'm proud
of every single woman standing up for
her rights standing up for the rights of
her sisters and daughters and I'm proud
of the many men supporting women's
rights openly it is essential
that all women around the world know
that they are valuable that they have
rights and these Brave women in Iran are
the reasons of why these rigid
structures begin to change so we as
politicians from other parts of the
world have to show the Iranian
government that we will not accept their
crimes against their own citizens not
accept their crimes against these Brave
women so rest Empower Masha and me
[Applause]
thank you very much and the next speaker
is Mrs Rafael one minute please
thank you chair since the murder of
Kurdish makta Gina amini 92 people have
died in Iran only because a brave woman
stood for her individual choice and the
individual choice of women in Iran is at
stake and all these women have fathers
just like Martha Gina Gina amini had a
father a man and I've been thinking of
what's been going on in his mind did I
protect my daughter enough did I give
enough resistance as a man in Iran to
the morality police is this because of a
piece of fabric and her identity that I
lost my daughter
what if our fathers stood up against the
oppressors of our daughters questions
like these will continuously go through
their minds in Iran and only with when
these fathers together with the strong
women in Iran stand up they can change
the regime of Iran commissioner we are
always clear about what we are against
but let's also be clear on what we stand
for these strong women currently in
danger need a safe haven and therefore
I'm asking the commission to investigate
whether Europe can offer this to them
thank you all this uh knock on my Watts
Jose thank you very much next speaker is
Mr Fernandez for one minute please third
president thank you very much president
vice president High representative
colleagues
first and foremost
we need to express our most sincere
condolences for the family the friends
of Masa amini
unfortunately and very sadly
she was assassinated by the Iranian
regime and we need to underscore that
this is not a unique case we even need
to ask ourselves is everything being
done to condemn to repudiate and to
avoid this sort of thing from
reproducing itself now the people of
Iran
believe in the rule of law they're
fighting for democracy and therefore our
duty should be to assist
and to
help those
thousands
and speak out for those thousands of
Iranians who were have been assassinated
by the regime and now I'd like to
conclude on this point the commission
should do all not just to condemn all of
this but to take those tangible actions
that I need potentially restrictive
measures that the high representative
referred to thank you
thank you next speaker is
one minute please
22 years old
and
she was detained by the morality please
this is the
virtue
please
and it is a scandal she was beaten went
into a coma and died three days later in
hospital this led to protests across the
world and has led to hundreds of people
being detained and injured in Iran the
Iranian security forces have responded
in an extremely violent Manner and they
are now allowing themselves to examine
women's clothing their head scarves
their hair the
clothes they are wearing and even their
makeup and if they are found in breach
then they risk going to prison these
kinds of laws are denigrating how can a
country
allow
a situation in which a piece of fabric
on a woman's head can lead to this
situation
women life Freedom that's Antonio thank
you the next speaker is Mr Lopez sister
is white one minute please
thank you very much president Hi
representative dear colleagues the
protests of the women and young people
have spread across all of Iran hundreds
have been killed just because they want
to live in a free Democratic country
they want to have the freedom to live
their lives not under the rules of the
ayatollahs
they're being constantly and brutally
repressed rather than listening to the
voices of those who want reform they
have opted for oppression brutality and
the murder of their citizens rather than
listening to the mothers and daughters
in Iran they have opted to censor their
voices and to persecute them it is our
duty to shine a light on what is
happening in Iran
colleagues a regime that does not listen
or respect to its own people are they
really a legitimate actor with whom we
should negotiate
we are often talking about not
negotiating agreements with countries
that do not respect human rights but the
EU is negotiating with a dictatorial and
fundamentalist state that of the
ayatollahs we should no longer do this
with this regime thank you um thank you
very much the next speaker is Mrs Walsh
for one minute please masamini and the
women of Iran are incredibly powerful
we've seen this first hand in large part
because of the instantaneous connection
we all have through social media and The
Bravery of our trusted and free
journalists the young women of Iran have
grown up in an age of digitization of
connectivity and because of this are
connected to the rest of the world in a
way that older Generations could never
imagine
they explore they learn they decide for
themselves they hear the voices and see
the faces of fellow change makers their
own age they are powerful
we are living in a Time thankfully where
young leaders are standing strong for
their rights for their freedoms for
their future they too see fundamental
rights are to be protected
Masa amini should never have lost her
life to hateful ideology never
while the Iranian government worked to
cut these Brave Young Women off from the
rest of the world we see what they are
fighting for these women will not be
silenced no woman should ever be their
protests are fundamentally changing the
course of history for the generations to
come we here in Europe stand with you in
the spirit of Masa amini thank you
yes um thank you and now I give the
floor to Mr Bellamy for one minute
please
the whole world is learning courage from
amini and all of those who have lost
their lives are at risk of losing their
lives for the simple reason that they
refuse to live hidden under a head scarf
and that's something that they did not
choose and that is imposed on them these
women are 20 some years of age they are
giving Europe a lesson in Courage
stating a freedom of conscious and
something that they're paying with the
ultimate price now High representative
I'm not sure if sanction is the right
word but whatever the case may be what
needs to be done is something so that we
are not silent in the face of the
assassination of the Youth of this
country now the European Parliament last
Junes voted on any issue and a
discussion of intersectionality in the
in in Banning the headscarf and where
would the feminists that are trying to
fight the patriarchy in our countries in
the U.S now we spoke out against this uh
campaign that the commission was funded
by you funds to fight for the freedom of
the hijab so we need to wonder accepting
the hijab as the at the head of the
Council of Europe are you not ashamed of
this when you think of all of those who
have passed in Iran amini first and
foremost knowing that it is time to
finally shed light on the guilty
complicity that has run has led to this
a horrible event
thank you the floor goes now to Mr
stefanek for one minute please
dear colleagues current demonstrations
in Iran following the deaths of
mashamini are going on for almost 20
days now these protests which have been
spread to all Iranian provinces have
been brutally repressed by the Iranian
regime and so far led to 400 deaths and
many injuries of people
including college and university
students in reality the number of deaths
could be much much higher I'm also very
concerned about the fate of more than 20
thousands of detainees where there is no
guarantee that their fundamental rights
are respected this reminds me of the
brutal suppression of the process in
November 2019. we all know that Iranian
regime is responding with severe
brutality but despite these Iranian
people are still on the streets so I do
believe
that the European Union should act now
and call on president ricey to stop the
pushback against the protesters
immediately and free the political
prisoners people in Iran deserve the
freedom and respecting basic human
rights thank you indeed
thank you very much colleagues now we
have a cage die procedure but as my
colleague Ottmar Karas already said that
we we are
much behind our agenda and timing so I
will give a floor only to three uh
speakers and first one is their
milanswer
thank you chair
after this murder
of mass amini the Iranian people again
Rose
first in 2019 and now once again
women are the fourth Forefront and this
protest might lead to changes
but even years ago and also today the
Iranian regime is doing everything to
prevent
the rebels to achieve democracy and
freedom
but I'm very glad to see today that the
whole European Parliament is very united
we all support the Iranian opposition in
their fight for democracy and freedom
this is good but what does Europe need
right now all European institutions
should be more effective and efficient
in this fight and we have not been so
efficient over the last years we have
not been decisive enough against this
regime and this regime has now become
even stronger they are now a military
and nuclear force and they are
threatening the whole region
thank you and this next speaker is a
margarita Marcus
thank you very much president about 10
years ago I was in Iran in a young
person with our guide
and gave me an insight into the life
there
and what we saw was that the hair would
slip out from under the headscarf and on
a daily basis would leave the house to
the university and was followed by those
who were policing her Morality In 78 the
Iranian women
began the fight for Freedom now we know
that the morality police is there trying
to condemn the women to be able to to
live in the way that they would like to
strip them of their rights High
representative we need European
solidarity with these women and now it
is fundamental and it is urgent
for all of those men and women that are
so with so much courage are standing up
and demanding their fundamental rights
not these are values that we have here
in the European Union but not only they
are Universal rights thank you
and now
Soleil uh please
the moles religious fundamentalist
killed Masha amini and the regime's
repressive nature is killing now dozens
of protesters many of them women who are
demanding life and Justice life in
Freedom and dignity all of three dining
regimes respond to popular unrest by
claiming that they are the result of
foreign interference because they are
simply unable to recognize that even
under the most brutal circumstances
there are always citizens willing to
sacrifice everything to defend human
rights human dignity and freedom we have
to stand by those protesting against the
repressive rule imposed on them we have
to use all the mechanisms at our
disposal to get the Iranian regime to
stop persecuting dissidents to stop
imposing policies and laws that attack
the most Elementary human rights and
finally opens up to a country diverse in
idologists thoughts religions and
minorities a democratic country where
Masha I mean he would never have become
the spark and the symbol that lead the
fire of protest
thank you very much we are closing cage
the eye procedure and I do apologize for
those who didn't get the floor so now I
would like to give a floor to high
representative Mr barrero Flores yours
Mr President and honorable members
these long debate testified your
continuing interest and engagement
on human rights
Iran in particular
we all share the shock for what happened
to misamini and for the violent
repression of the protest
we also share the same support for the
courage of the Iranian people who are
demonstrating in the streets and facing
a difficult situation
we will continue to follow what's
happening in the country and to use
every opportunity
to raise our positions and our concerns
that you might write in Iran
as I mentioned we will continue to
consider all the options of our disposal
including restricted measures the
foreign office Council will decide about
it on the next meeting
this will be
addressed this college colleagues sorry
in the colleagues in two weeks from now
and I am sure that they will react
accordingly with your wishes and
concerns
thank you
thank you very much um
I have received seven emotions for
Resolutions to wind up this debate and
the debate is closed now the vote will
be held on Thursday
oops
an announcement now the parliament on
the basis of Eureka mathi checks
Patricia chanyan
Mariachi Marina Majorca I apologize if I
don't pronounce correct correctly Eric
menardly the mandates of those persons
who which come into Force came in force
on the 9th of July and also Mrs Anna
Miranda which come into force on the 5th
of September and Joe I'll book